רשתות נוירונים הן סוג עוצמתי של אלגוריתמי למידת מכונה
והן מגיעות בהרבה סוגים שונים
אין שום אפשרות לתת תשומת לב מספקת לרשתות נוירונים
בסרטון מבוא
כמו זה פה אנחנו רק נזהה כמה רכיבי מפתח
של רשת נוירונים ואת תהליך העבודה הכולל
כדי שנוכל להבין איך מחשוב קוונטי יכול לתרום
רשת הנוירונים היא גרף מחובר של נוירונים
נוירון הוא בעצם סתם דבר שמחזיק מספר
והמספר הזה נקרא לעתים קרובות הפעלה - כמה
דלוק או כבוי הנוירון הוא
הנוירונים ממוינים בשכבות
והשכבה הראשונה היא שכבת הקלט
והאחרונה היא שכבת הפלט
באמצע יש שכבות שמשמשות לעיבוד שנקראות
שכבות נסתרות - ההפעלה של
שכבת הקלט פשוט נטענת ישירות מהנתונים שצריך לנתח
כמו הצללת הפיקסלים בתמונה
ההפעלות של השכבה הנסתרת הבאה נקבעות
על ידי הנוירונים בשכבת הקלט
ועל ידי משקלים שמסומלים על ידי הקווים שמחברים את כל הנוירונים
בשכבת הקלט לכל הנוירונים ב-
שכבה הבאה - במילים אחרות, אנחנו קובעים את ההפעלה
של נוירון בשכבה הנסתרת
על ידי סכום ממושקל של כל
הפעלות הקלט, אנחנו יכולים
גם להחיל הטיה - הזזה
אולי נרצה להפעיל נוירון
בשכבה הנסתרת לא רק אם הסכום הממושקל הוא
חיובי אלא רק אם הוא עובר סף גבוה
לאחר מכן אנחנו לעתים קרובות מחילים פונקציה מסובכת כדי לקבל הפעלה
בין אפס לאחד, כמו טנגנס היפרבולי
או לפעמים בצורה שונה -
יחידה לינארית מתוקנת, אין צורך לדאוג
יותר מדי מאלה עכשיו, הדבר היחיד
החשוב לציין פה לגבי הפונקציות האלה
הוא שהן לא לינאריות
כך שהרשת כולה מכילה גם רכיבים לינאריים
וגם רכיבים לא לינאריים
אותו סכום ממושקל של הפעלות, הפעם
מתחיל עם ההפעלות של
השכבה הנסתרת הראשונה והמשקלים החדשים
מגיע עד לשכבה הנסתרת הבאה
זה ממשיך עד לשכבה האחרונה שהיא פלט
שכבת הפלט כוללת נוירונים שמתאימים ל-
קטגוריות וההפעלות אומרות לנו
כמה הרשת בטוחה בסיווג
אז קטגוריות הפלט בניתוח תמונות עשויות להיות
כלב, חתול, אוגר וכן הלאה
והפעלה של 0.95 על
נוירון הכלב תציין רמה גבוהה של ודאות ש-
התמונה היא של כלב - אפשר להתחיל את הרשת הנוירונלית שלך
עם קבוצה אקראית של משקלים
והטיות, או מתצורת התחלה סבירה ידועה
אבל אז הרעיון הוא לבדוק
עד כמה הרשת הנוירונלית שלך מסווגת דברים
ולשפר אותה - אנחנו משתמשים בפונקציית עלות כדי לתאר
את הסטייה של הרשת הנוירונלית שלנו מ-
סיווג נכון - זה כולל לקיחת ה-
הפרש בין הערך האמיתי של תמונה
נגיד למשל ערך של אחד על הנוירון
של כלב ואפס על כל שאר נוירוני הפלט
לבין הערכים החזויים
אנחנו מסכמים על כל הקטגוריות
אז אנחנו עוקבים לא רק אם הקטגוריה הנכונה הייתה
הכי מופעלת, אלא אנחנו יכולים
גם לעקוב אם הפעלות שגויות מופחתות
בסכום על כל הדוגמאות בסט האימון שלנו
ולקבל עלות - אנחנו אז
משנים את הפרמטרים כמו המשקלים בכל שכבה
בין כל הנוירונים וההטיות על כולם
משתמשים בשגרות אופטימיזציה קלאסיות
כדי לחפש מינימום מקומי בפונקציית העלות
אם לא עושים שום דבר כדי להפחית את המורכבות של זה
אפשר לדמיין איזה
מרחב פרמטרים אסטרונומי הכנו פה
בואו נחשוב על רשת נוירונים שתוכננה לנתח תמונות עם
רק אלף פיקסלים - לרשת הנוירונים הזו אולי יש אלף
נוירוני קלט, שכבה נסתרת בודדת בלבד
ופלט בינארי כמו חתול או כלב
זה המקרה הפשוט ביותר
ועדיין מתאים לאלף כפול אלף
או מיליון משקלים בין שכבות הקלט והנסתרת
ועוד אלפיים בין ה-
שכבות הנסתרת והפלט
אולי גם אלף או
משהו כזה הטיות - אז הרשת הנוירונלית הפשוטה הזו תתאים
ליותר ממיליון פרמטרים - אבל להיות הוגנים
אלגוריתמים מודרניים בדרך כלל כן עושים פישוטים
ברשתות נוירונים קלאסיות
ויש תחומים שלמים שמוקדשים להפיכת המינימיזציה הזו
לאפשרית ואפילו יעילה
אבל העובדה נשארת שזו בעיה עם
ממד גבוה מאוד
ואימון רשת נוירונים
יכול לקחת הרבה זמן
ולעלות הרבה - רשת נוירונים קוונטית, או QNN
עובדת על ידי טעינת נתוני הקלט תחילה
ואז על ידי החלת circuit-ים קוונטיים
שמתאימים למשקלים בין שכבות
ולבסוף שכבת מדידה
כמה נקודות מפתח על זה - הנתונים
הטעינה וההמתנות הן פעולות לינאריות
אבל המדידות הן לא לינאריות
אז כמו ברשתות נוירונים קלאסיות, יש לנו
גם רכיבים לינאריים וגם רכיבים לא לינאריים
גם ה-circuit-ים של המשקלים
עדיין יש להם פרמטרים וריאציוניים
אז עדיין יש מינימיזציה קלאסית שצריך לבצע
כמובן שזה רק שרט את פני השטח של רשתות נוירונים קוונטיות
אבל אנחנו מקווים שתמשיכו ללמוד על היישומים
של רשתות נוירונים קוונטיות
ויישומי למידת מכונה קוונטית אחרים
עם IBM Quantum